good evening thanks for joining us i'm
denise valdez and i'm christian casadas
new information tonight about the future
of the fountain blue in las vegas so the
marriott is no longer part of that
project but developers tell joe moeller
after more than a decade they are
bringing back their original vision for
the building joe's live on the north end
of the strip with the details for us
up until recently marriott had the jw
marriott las vegas boulevard listed on
their website but when you go to that
link it no longer works so it appears
that project is no longer happening well
the fountain blue development tells us
their original vision for this building
which was found in blue las vegas is now
back on it's an eyesore that's for sure
visitors have taken notice to the empty
big blue building so i would be saying
hey you guys got to take care of that
one way or the other it towers over the
strip and has sat empty for years it
appears it will stay that way up until
recently marriott had a website
detailing a future plan for a jw
marriott las vegas boulevard at the
location that site is now gone a
marriott spokesperson tells 8 news now
the company has exited the project it's
disappointing to see mayor because they
would have been a great
tenant for the building a spokesperson
for fountain blue development who is a
partial owner of the building says in
part we intend to fulfill our original
vision and deliver the same
extraordinary hospitality experience
that our guests have come to expect from
fountain blue development ziggerblum
says movement has to happen they have to
make substantial progress in two years
but within one year they have to which
would be like next march they have to
clean up the outside and make it
presentable the mountain blue's original
plan was to build the 2.8 billion hotel
to open in 2009 the project went
bankrupt sigerblum says a well-known
company could flourish there it either
have some
national international company that can
tie itself to the convention business
because that's a prime location
out here live mountain blue development
did not clarify if it will be called the
fountain blue las vegas once again like
it was supposed to be originally but
they say they will be operating the
building once it does open reporting
live joe mullen live local now
joe apparently there's been some kind of
activity or construction going on
outside do we have an idea if that's
just about maintenance or maybe
something for the future
yeah well for the past several weeks
we've seen crews out there actually
doing work and we are told by the
commissioner that within the first year
they do have to make improvements to the
building to make it look a little more
presentable from the strip and then
within two years we have to have some
sort of deal to get something going on
there i'll send it back to you it's been
bacon for so long all right joe thanks
for that update